this is
hello everyone a very warm good evening
or good morning we'll be starting with
the session in about 10 minutes
meanwhile we begin with the session you
can introduce yourself in the chat box
and let us know about your background
and your research interests
foreign
I would like to welcome you all to
today's session we'll be starting in
more 5 to 10 minutes we are waiting for
other participants to join as well
and meanwhile we begin with today's
session you could introduce yourself in
the chat box and let us know about your
background and your research interests
thank you
a very warm good morning good afternoon
or good evening in whichever part of the
world you are I would like to welcome
you all to today's first session on
introduction to bioinformatics in art so
before we begin with today's session I
would like to introduce ourselves for
those who have joined us for the very
first time and then I would pass on the
stage to Dr raghavendran to begin with
the session
so as the need for management and
Analysis of data grows coding is
becoming a must-have skill for
bioinformations this does not have to be
overwhelming career change for a
biologist so our team put together
Elementary tutorials to understand
programming Basics using examples of
loading analysis and visualization of
structured data our programming offers a
complete range of functionality that you
can leverage to perform in-depth
statistical analysis visualization and
annotation getting started can be hard
programming is like learning a new
language altogether that is why we offer
easy to follow structure and simple
coding tutorials designed around
bioinformatics challenges by completing
this course anyone will be able to
utilize this popular coding language to
create objects to utilize this using
predefined packages used by
bioinformations in various research
projects
to introduce myself I am sonali Curry
and I am the bioinformatics project
manager at Pine biotech and to introduce
our company we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and Commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
I would now like to introduce the
founders and team members of the company
Dr Alfred topper comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of his major
projects is the establishment of topple
bioinformatics Research Center which has
been at the core of what we do
Dr Leonard Brodsky is the director of
topper bioinformatics Research Center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
power statistics our platform is a
result of hard work by some of the
people mentioned here on the right Julia
panoff is an expert bioinformatician
habitat of scheme leads the development
of the T bioinfo platform Dr Mohit
mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformations with multiple
Publications in peer-reviewed journals
he has been developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project need for omixel logic training
and research Fellowship
is an accomplished computational
biologist with an experience in large
scale analysis of multi-omics data and
data science methods in Precision
oncology and protein DNA structural
bioinformatics
so how do omix logic resources help
Advance bioinformatics teaching omics
logic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge or mix
logic takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give a student
a clear path of the Bloom's taxonomy
pyramid and no matter what the user's
initial experience with bioinformatics
is omix logic is a useful tool for
gaining a baseline knowledge of the
theory behind bioinformatics analysis of
large data sets an introduction to basic
coding languages like R and python are
beginning a data analysis project
altogether
this program comes with an access to the
omics logic courses which includes
courses and bioinformatics precision
medicine multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using R and Python and
also the users will get an access to
various example projects or case studies
I must say of different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work
users will also be given the directions
to access the T bioinfo platform for
bioinformatics processing and Analysis
of different types of data in these
different resources that I just
mentioned
so without a Much Ado let's first of all
Begin by signing up on the omics logic
learn portal
I'll just take it through the portal
once you have signed up you need to make
sure that you have completed your
profile now a complete profile will
include a profile image full name with
proper capitalization you must link your
social media handles that is Facebook
LinkedIn Instagram or ID or Twitter and
add update bio about yourself that will
consist of educational background and
research interests
the mentors can view your progress under
the activities Tab and the courses that
you are currently completing will appear
under the courses Tab and finally after
the completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificate stamp
so for those who have registered for the
program I would like to take you through
some of the things that you have to keep
a note of throughout the program
before I do that I would paste the link
in the chat box so that you all can sign
up on the portal or just see has already
shared thank you so much
those who are new and have joined the
session for the first time and have not
signed up yet on the portal please take
some time to sign up on the portal so
that you can get along with us today we
will be following some resources from
the portal itself today and practice
some code sessions it will be helpful to
you if you have an account on the portal
already
you can take a minute to sign up if you
are on your system
those who have already signed up can put
a yes or one in the chat box so that we
know we are good to proceed ahead and
others can take this sign to sign up
here I can see two responses in the chat
from the audience
all right so those who have already
signed up the next step for you is to
complete your profile as I mentioned
that we'll be monitoring your progress
at the back end so it's very important
for us to know what background you come
from and what are your research and
trusts knowing them only will help us to
align the resources for you you need to
make sure that you have your profile
complete as I just told through my
presentation and after the course for
completion your certificates will appear
here another certificates tab
now I wanted to go through the program
page with all of you to tell you where
you would find the resources for the
specific program for which we are
meeting today
so this is the program page
I'll just put the link in the chat
so this program page is very important
for those who have registered for the
program please bookmark this page on
this page you'll find the link to join
the zoom session when the when the
schedule uh is placed for all of these
sessions so you need to just click on
the zoom icon and you will be able to
join the meeting so you have the
schedule here for all these sessions you
have the dates mentioned
sorry and you also have the topics that
would be covered in each in each and
every session now once the session is
complete you will find the recording of
this session on the program page itself
if you are not able to join the session
let's say you have some prior
commitments at that time and you are not
able to join the session then you can
watch the recording from the program
page itself and let us know in Skype
group if you have any questions so that
we could help you clarify them and
proceed ahead
for each and every session you have some
Associated online resources which are
present here now these resources are
lessons and courses on the omics logic
learn portal itself so you need to make
sure that for each session that we have
put together on the program page you
need to watch the recording if you miss
the session you can revisit the
recording as well to revise the concepts
and then you need to complete the uh
resources that are present here under
each and every session these all
resources are hyperlinked you just need
to click on them and you'll be
redirected to the specific lesson that
you are required to go through
in the first session today we'll be just
introducing you to bioinformatics and
also introduce you to the language some
of you might not have a bioinformatics
background so that is why we will also
introduce you to the field
bioinformatics and the role of big data
and bioinformatics before we actually
get started so today we'll be just an
introductory session for all of you to
get started and then we'll dig deep into
the concepts
and once you complete the session you
are required to click on the complete
session button once you click on the
complete session button for all of these
sessions that we have put together on
the program page doing so will help you
get the certificate towards the end of
the program again in your profile
section so that was all about how you
can monitor all the resources that we'll
be providing you with as a part of this
program
this was about the resources the second
thing comes communication you all are
requested to join the Skype group so
that you stay in regular touch with our
team and the mentor and whenever you go
through these resources and encounter
any question or doubt that you might
like to clarify you can ping us and
we'll help you with your questions we'll
also have a live q a session where you
are supposed to come up with all your
questions to get them clarified from the
mentor so that was about communication
and now let's begin with the session
I'll now like to pass on the stage to Dr
raghav
to start over with the first session
over to user
thank you and very welcome very warm
welcome to everybody let's see let me
set up my screen sharing
can you see my screen and can you hear
me clearly yes your screen is coming up
I can hear you clearly I can see your
screen now thank you sir okay thank you
very much I'm also following the chat
box so if you have any queries quickly
respond to me in the chat so
um most of this is let's set it up okay
yeah so welcome one more time to today's
session so we are going to asanalika
mentioned uh already so we are going to
deal with uh getting started with
bioinformatics in R and uh some of the
background uh
um necessary information about uh how
are we what is the kind of data that we
are going to deal with uh when we have
to perform bioinformatics analysis in R
and where does this data come from what
are the processing steps that are that
are involved in generating these
structured data so that will be our
starting session today and today also I
will show you when we have time uh how
to access couple of lessons are coded
lessons or coding lessons from the learn
portal and also show you the inbuilt
console our console that we have uh
introduced or that we have incorporated
into the learn portal itself so that you
can learn and test your knowledge or
just pass some of the challenges that we
have set for you to understand your
learning in the same page itself for the
same web link or same learn portal page
itself so that is going to be very
convenient as we move along so let's
quickly get get started
so
let's begin with the question what is
bioinformatics right so it is for
example it can be regarded as a
convergence of biology and data where
both are equally important and
we will also see in next few slides how
the data part and the biology part come
come into
becoming equally important uh in this in
this field and
let's ask another question for example
what do we use bioinformatics for our
better question is who are who uses
bioinformatics and who will benefit from
these analysis right so the answer might
be for example people who are
statisticians or or computer scientists
or Engineers they may be interested in
bioinformatics because largely we are
going to deal with data and these are
all the people who are associated with
data for large part of their career but
for the last few years the truth is like
more and more biologists and more
clinicians are actually involved in
understanding their data from
bioinformatics analysis there it is not
luxury now but it is now expected that
biologists and clinicians are able to
handle their own data and they are able
to for example understand the patterns
in the data and in order to be
successful in basic and translational
research we have to use some form of
bioinformatics or data analytics for our
biological data from from biologists and
clinician stem cells right so this has
sparked a transformation which
actually transforms the science of
biology itself into a science that is
rapidly acquiring characteristics of uh
something like data science part so how
is this
transformation acquired for example we
can see that in today's era biology is
about
um
can be defined or can be described as
some uh
part of data science because billions
and billions of data points and genes
proteins and other molecules are
actually compiled in a large file and
they are systematically studied so these
characteristics or visible
characteristics of biology actually
makes them very close only resemble the
characteristics of data science right
and these data right just like any other
data and analyzing these data by
incorporating or by using standard data
science analytical tools will lead to
more knowledge and will lead to more
understanding about the
biology of the living organisms about
for example understanding on the
biotechnology part understanding for
example crops livestock Health
applications of this data so so thus we
have actually invented or actually
bioinformatics has has become a new uh
field in itself where it can
self-sustain the interpretations and
self-sustained the analysis that it is
actually creating from the data that are
available from biology biological
resources so
this humongous amount of data or volume
of data that we will see in in a few
slides that has been generated from uh
for biological science for biological
understanding understanding of the
biology of example uh has its uh
influence in for example development of
the associated methodologies and
development of some specific resources
like uh uh approaches that are purely
data driven
for understanding biological phenomena
or for understanding the biology of the
system and these characteristics as we
spoke about are actually driving bio
bioinformatics are actually driving
biology to more and more look like
data driven science or data-driven
approaches right
and long forgotten or long before
biology was used as a hypothesis driven
study where you generally start your
investigation based on prior
understanding of a system and then you
develop a hypothesis on the relationship
that you have
um understood that you have knowledge on
based on previous studies or based on uh
another portion of experiments that you
have already understood and this
hypothesis will fuel data generation and
then subsequently data analysis to
validate this hypothesis but today
since the availability of data is large
and it's in huge volumes the data-driven
approaches are more and more common
where people start looking for patterns
in the data to begin with right even
before starting to formulate a theory or
a hypothesis they start to look for
patterns in the data and then once some
of the patterns are evident and some of
the patterns are not very uh very well
defined so they start making this
hypothesis and making this relationship
between the patterns that they observe
and the phenotypical characteristics and
they can start analyzing this data in a
more systematic manner to
get to the bottom of this analysis and
get to the complete understanding of the
biology behind the system so
so we spoke about big data and large
amount of large volumes of data right
and where are these data coming from and
and what generates this data and this
data is based on for example High
throughput Technologies or next
Generation sequencing technologies that
can generate billions and billions of
data points on genes that will become
genomics data and proteins and other
molecules that will become subsequently
transcriptomics and proteomics and other
data right and these multi different
omics data are actually compiled into
repositories and they can be
systematically studied and understood
and they can be
interrogated for establishing trends for
many different applications right and
so where are these where is this data
and what's out there and this such data
available for everybody to access uh the
one short answer to that question is yes
and we have as a part of biological
research have been extremely familiar
with one such repository that is
maintained by national Center for
biotechnology information and uh this is
one of the most famous repository that
has a collection of all the
peer-reviewed Articles biological data
sets projects on various topics and etc
etc right so
yeah we have definitely used PubMed
where we can see many of uh
published uh peer-reviewed articles and
we can actually
um
identify data sets from understanding or
from uh scanning through several of
these Publications from PubMed databases
and one of the associated resources of
databases that we will definitely
discuss in the in the future sessions is
the Geo or gene expression Omniverse
database which which is a collection of
thousands and thousands of
um small
transcriptomics data an rnac data and
single cell organizing data and multi
metagenomic Theta and several other data
that are compiled for public access and
public analysis so we will definitely
use some of these data assets and in the
next few sessions and in the upcoming
sessions we will also discuss how to
download data sets from publicly
available resources and what what is
this data set and what can we what are
the type of analysis that we can perform
from this data asset and how to set up
these specific analysis for the data set
that you have selected or that we have
focused on so those those things will
become very clear when we discuss in
those specific sessions
so so we actually discussed for example
uh
biology and bioinformatics acquiring
properties of data science so uh so what
are these specific properties of data
science that are related to a
bioinformatics data or biological data
right so to give you an uh brief
overview of for example data science
um data science is a scientific
field that involves developing methods
of recording or storing and analyzing
data to for example effectively extract
useful information
so the ultimate goal of data science is
to gain knowledgeable insights from any
type of data both structured and
unstructured or sometimes
semi-structured so
unstructured data is what you typically
would have to deal with when
um
when you are trying to acquire data from
publicly available resources right and
this unstructured data can be for
example
understood as Loosely organized data of
different categories like
your emails or like your for example uh
tweets and like survey data which will
also discuss shortly and this has to be
prepared for analysis to make a complete
make it completely useful or to extract
more and more knowledge from these
unstructured data this has to be
now prepared and this has to be
structured into some uh some form where
we can apply some statistical analysis
for understanding inferences from this
data so what do I mean by unstructured
and structured data let's to illustrate
this concept and let's try to for
example conduct a mock survey so if I
were to ask you what is your educational
background the responses might be
extremely varied for example somebody
some might respond like
um I am a graduate student and some
might actually give a very detailed
response like I have a degree in
computer science specializing in network
and that said that and etc etc right and
um
others might actually give acronyms of
their
degree that they are going to that they
are going through so these are all
varied responses but I cannot make out a
lot of things from these responses as a
human if I have to go through these uh
resources or these um responses then I
get a good idea but if the number of
data points increase uh
a lot then a human element becomes
really uh difficult to incorporate and
we have to rely on um analytical methods
and algorithmic methods to understand
the patterns in this data so what are
the patterns that we are looking for in
order to make it little bit uh more
structured we can actually introduce
structure into some data collection
techniques like this survey right by
replacing the information uh with actual
options that you can choose from right I
can give you options based on which I
can make some inferences
um of this structured data generation
but this actually uh
reduces the kind of information that I
might be able to obtain right so I will
not probably cover all of the options
that is available there so hence uh
introducing structure into the data will
actually promote a lot of analysis which
is absolutely necessary but it can also
result in loss of
quantity of data or loss of variation in
the data sometimes it is
um
um uh sometimes which is considered as a
necessary uh
evil right so we cannot do a lot with
unstructured data so either we take the
unstructured data and introduce
structure by analyzing the outputs which
again will lead to might lead to loss of
data but uh generally this is to um
get you or give you an understanding
that we need structured data to be able
to perform statistical analysis and to
make some
um
valid and valuable insights from the
data we understand the trends of the
data like uh like it's given so so same
can be uh extended to any kind of data
specifically big data which is our
primary interest here right so big data
in its uh
at its ultimate or at its basic level
has certain characteristics that we have
to keep in mind and a big biological
data or bioinformatics data is not is
not
an exemption from this so uh they are
characterized by several characteristics
but some of the important
characteristics that we have to keep in
mind is
um
is the velocity variability and volume
so we we know that it is uh the volume
is humongous because it uh we know the
quantity of data that we are dealing
with is in terms of GBS and GB sometimes
it can be also reach terabytes and we
know the variability is also uh a major
factor because some of the omics data
types like uh metagenomics data types
and the single cell transcriptomic data
types are so vary that um
alternative methods of analysis might
not be very fruitful in understanding
the patterns in the data and we know
about velocity also because the data
keeps on increasing in its quantity
every year so we can see that
um
we can see that when we analyzing the
amount of data that is deposited to
repositories like ncbi and other
databases from where we can download uh
these omics data types so
so that helps us understand for example
the necessity to structure any data and
largely importantly to structure omics
data right so how can we introduce
structure or how can we convert a raw or
mixed data which is predominantly
unstructured to a structured omics data
which is absolutely necessary for
analysis like that we are going to
perform in in the following sessions
right so
just to introduce structure or to
structure omics data we basically need
to take the raw sequencing data which is
in the format of string of letters a t g
and c and to generate a data set or to
generate a matrix of continuous or
categorical data which can be analyzed
in a statistical environment so to do
that we have to organize
um a steps of processing algorithm in
sequences which we will refer to as
pipelines and these analysis pipelines
are specific to particular type of omics
data so for example for genomics we will
have to set up a different pipeline of
analysis methods and for transcriptomics
and metagenomics we will have to set up
a different
combination of algorithms for their
pipeline setup
so that's how we can structure any omics
data type based on
based on the sequence of analysis
algorithms that are available for that
to handle that specific Comics data type
so
um
so what do we have in the public the
positive is for example
um if publicly available data is is
majority I mean a majority of the
publicly available data is unstructured
then some portion of that data is also
structured and that is also available so
when you simply compare for example we
have a lots and lots of data that is
unstructured compared to some portion of
the data that is structured and also
publicly available so it is more
convenient for us to take the
unstructured data and perform the
analysis pipeline an example pipeline
that we will also refer to in the
upcoming few slides and then generate
our own structured data for
uh for the analysis that we are
interested in why is this convenient
this is majorly convenient because
sometimes
um
the analysis methods might get upgraded
and the necessary to generate a new
structured data might be necessary to
um
to effectively understand the patterns
in the data right and sometimes we will
get new information based on some
updates that that is uh that has been
discovered or there has been unreal a
major source or major example for this
will be the difference between analysis
that is performed on the HG 19 a
previous version of reference human
genome compared with the HG 38 a newer
version of human reference genome so the
newer version will obviously include
mapping of sequences to different
portions of the genome and then
definitely will give us information on
this new location or new genes and new
uh genomic positions that are not
covered in the previous version
analysis that uses the previous version
so
so it's much better if we are going to
consider or we will consider
unstructured data and then a device
our own analysis Pipeline with the
latest available algorithms and latest
available reference genomes to arrive at
most updated pattern that we can use for
uh
Downstream analysis that we will
definitely
discuss in the future sessions
so to achieve this specific result for
example to uh or achieve structuring of
the data we will usually take
first Q files or raw data let's consider
genomics data right let's consider
genomics data so to structure genomics
data we will take raw first few files
and then run a pipeline for example
called variant calling pipeline this
pipeline will give you an output of all
the list of variants that one can
identify in the sample that has been
sequenced compared to the reference
genome that we just discussed in a short
while so the pipeline generally might
include several of the steps that are
that are categorized as pre-processing
steps mapping algorithms and Then
followed by analysis of these map
regions like somatic variant calling
steps to produce the list or to produce
a table that we can perform form
Downstream analysis with
so for example when we use the first key
files that is generated from shotgun
sequencing or high throughput NGA
sequencing like Illumina right we will
generate lots and lots of short reads of
sequences that are
sequenced from randomly selected
fragments of DNA or RNA so generally uh
this these fragments will have to be
aligned to their reference genome and
once aligned to the reference genome and
these short reads can be analyzed for
mismatches and non-matches or deletions
to the reference system these mismatches
are the ones that we are going to
characterize for the data in the in the
event of genomics data analysis for the
sample that we have sequenced
uh these region right and these
mismatches or non-matches for example in
oncology let's say in oncological
context can be analyzed for their
mutation status which are often referred
to as somatic mutations or
um mutations that are
observed in the tumor tissue compared to
the normal tissue that is very closely
situated in the biological side and
these list of mutations will be very
important to understand how they might
affect some of the important genes that
are involved in let's say tumor growth
or tumor disease progression Etc
etcetera so to analyze such a data we
can prepare a table of somatic scores
for each and every genomic position and
that table can be fed into for example
uh
more detailed or more uh
Advanced Downstream analysis that can
also involve a statistical tests or can
involve machine learning analysis to
identify
genes that has that are associated with
statistically relevant somatics course
compared to the normal so this is one
way where we can
go from uh raw sequence data to a table
or a list of structured data and then
subject that table or list of structured
data into statistical analysis and uh
other
Advanced statistical analysis to extract
meaningful insights from this data
right so another example that is mostly
referred to in many of the Publications
is the transcriptomics data and this
data represents the MRNA expression
which is a good way to analyze what are
the processes that are going on inside
the cell by observing the active
transcription of the protein coding
genes right we all already know by this
stage that the DNA is transcribed into
RNA and the RNA is what is translated
into proteins so by measuring these
messenger RNA we can understand what are
the proteins that are
essentially available in what abundance
in the cells uh particular state
right but for example this
and this method or this transcriptomics
data analysis will also give additional
information than just giving you
quantification of genes and their uh
expression levels for example the
protein coding genes in the genomic DNA
that we already know may contain large
structures of non-coding sequences that
are called introns right and we also
know that some portions of these introns
are actually spliced or not not some
actually all most of these interns are
spliced out of the RNA transcript by
splicer so and these splicing can
actually change the constituents or
change the um
uh parts of the gene that may be uh that
may be resulting that that may result in
one or other isoforms of that same gene
so these isoforms may actually be uh
lead to or may be associated with for
example
um uh the disease state or alternate
state of the cell and their expression
levels can be
analyzed and Associated and generally
linked with the altered state of the
cell that we are interested in
um
characterizing
right so a typical analysis for let's
say transcriptomics data or rna-seq data
no both are safe transcriptomics is uh
they might include other forms of
quantifying messenger RNA like
microarray right and uh and um
targeted uh sequencing but rna-seq is
just one uh
Next Generation sequencing technology
involving method to quantify all the
messenger rnas that are present in the
cell so transcriptomics is umbrella RNA
RNA seek is a major technique which
generates large portions of this
transcriptomics data
so before this RNA sequence uh involved
uh transcriptomics analysis was
performed using microarray sequence
sequencing or microarray technology
impact right not sequencing microarray
targeted probing Technologies so that is
the difference
so but nowadays it is actually used uh
synonymously because majority of the
transcriptomics data analysis is done
using rna-seq platforms
so a typical analysis pipeline for the
data that comes from this next
Generation sequence in technology and
our rnac data for example will allow us
to uh again a map that okay what
happened my yeah to allow us to for
example pre-process the input files
right the first few files and then clean
for any presence of adapter sequences
and Etc and also clean some of the
PCR duplicates that are found and then
and then um we have to map these
pre-processed reads onto the respective
genes in the human genome and then uh
quantify these mapped reads
um or quantify these genes based on the
number of reads that are mapped onto
that specific uh gems this can often or
this will often be followed by
Downstream analysis that involves
estimation of differential gene
expression which identifies genes that
are expressed specific to one type of
sample compared to the other
so as a result of this quantification of
this rnac data you will be able to
obtain a table of continuous numeric
data that is annotated by Gene ID and
organized consistently across different
samples in a given experiment so you
will have for example along the columns
um that
the expression levels that are
Quantified for different samples and
along the rows you will get the
expression levels that are Quantified
for different genes as given by their
Ensemble ID in this case
yeah so their intersection you will get
expression levels for the type of
normalization that you have chosen in
this case it is fpkm or TPM values and
you can also choose a normalized count
or raw counts or an rpkm as other
options of normalization that you can
obtain from this pipeline of analysis so
this structured data can again be
directly used to for example perform a
simple statistical Association and
Analysis test where we can use t-test to
find out or detested to on
understand gene expression levels of
those genes which are
different in let's say altered cell
State compared to the control cell state
right this can be elevated or this can
be further applied using a specific
algorithms such as deseg 2 which
performs the same differential gene
expression analysis
using convoluted or using more
statistical statistically defined
methods to identify differentially
Express genes that are expressed
specific to one condition compared to
the earth this can again for example be
used to perform Advanced statistical
analysis like machine learning analysis
which can
identify genes
behind for example
um uh behind
categorizing tumors into their
subcategories or genes behind tumor
progression and their treatment response
depending upon the data and More Sample
characteristics and clinical
characteristics of the samples that we
can accumulate we can keep varying the
kind of Downstream analysis for the
question that we are interested in from
such a wealthy update
and another type of data that we will
definitely review in this course comes
from same sequencing technique the Next
Generation sequencing technique but it
does offer a completely different view
of the biological sample
we will deal in detail in in some of the
resources like the RNA sequences are in
basically the reads are have to be
cleaned for the presence of duplicate
sequences and biases so the cleaned and
trimmed reads to maintain high quality
sequences right
reads are then mapped onto their
respective positions in the genome so
what are the respective positions since
the data that we are involved with is
transcriptomics data so we are going to
get reads only from the messenger RNA or
only from the exons of these genomes so
you take the reference genome and then
map these reads onto those specific
portions right specific genes and this
can form the basis of Simply counting
the number of reads that is present or
that is aligned to that specific Gene so
this is very oversimplification of how
this uh reads are converted into counts
but the algorithms such as for example
HTC or RSM will perform expectation
maximization processes to correct for
the length of the gene which will
obviously have a positive or have a
direct correlation with the amount of
reads that can be mapped and for example
biasedness that are introduced generally
to certain portions of the genome that
is prone to getting a lot of
fragments generated at the library
preparation stage so
at its simple level
converting RNA sequences into accounts
is just counting the number of shattered
reads from that specific portions of the
sample that can be mapped onto any
particular Gene in the reference Gene
and that is complex level this will
actually involve cleaning up mapping
mapping up accurate mapping accurately
and also to perform
uh expectation maximization algorithm
took on for some of the biases and other
variations that we observed so let's
come back to this metagenomic sequencing
data so as I mentioned this offers a
completely different view from the same
sequencing technique that we have been
discussing so far the Next Generation
sequencing technique or high throughput
sequencing Tech right so in this case we
are looking at sample that contains
millions and billions of microbes or
microorganisms that are represented by
genomes that are very different from
each other right so to structure this
data and to organize this
hugely varied genomic information into
categories we can take for example a
functionally related Gene that is to
that is common to all of the organisms
right like the ribosomal Gene which can
be compared to a databases of known
sequences of ribosomal genes and their
taxonomy identify so that is what is
roughly been done in the metagenomic
sequencing data so this ribosomal Gene
that we are going to consider is the 16s
ribosomal RNA RNA Gene and the
on the sequencing and the analysis that
we are going to perform from this uh
from sequencing this 16s rrna Gene is
commonly referred to as amplicon data
analysis that can be used that can be
done in for example in the talk about
bioinfo platform using two options data
two and also using kind 2 analysis so as
a result of this you can for example uh
obtain proportions of taxonomic groups
of samples
that can be analyzed to understand a
sample diversity or that can be analyzed
to understand the proportionate
abundance of specific uh
microorganism that can and
disproportionate abundance of specific
microorganisms like let's say in this
case you can generally see in this
output
um the pink portion of these bar plots
which refers to
varico microbac and that are abundant in
only these samples and that are not at
all found in this sample can be linked
to the phenotypical variation and can be
linked to the to understand the
biological biology behind the sample
that we are trying to characterize so
this is the end result but what is the
structured data that you will definitely
or that you will generally deal with and
that you will generally obtain from
metagenomics data analysis is
it is also a table of uh uh quantific
Quantified data and the
quantity that has been Quantified is the
operational taxonomic units uh which are
actually uh
um
tabulated for their abundance levels
across different samples right we have
again the samples organized as columns
and operational taxonomic units which
can refer to specific or which can refer
to more closely related
microbes that can be
identified with their taxonomic ranks
right so
otu1 and otu 2 and 3 are respective
um can be understood as respective
microbes that can be
um
whose identity can be understood by
comparing a whose identity can be
estimated by comparing the known
database of 16s rrna and there taxonomic
Association so this is what has been
done in the metagenomic data analysis
where you get two kinds of information
on the first level you will get this
abundance
table or abundance information which
tabulates or which quantifies the
abundance of this taxonomic units across
different samples and in the second
layer of information we will get the
taxonomic identification of these
respective taxonomic units and hence we
can make
um
the inferences like what we actually
discussed in couple of slides ago where
we can specifically identify the kind of
uh Kingdom phyla or class level
organization of samples that are
proportionately abundant in one
particular group of samples compared to
the other
right this is what we can actually do
and to perform such analysis uh in in
majority of the programming environment
uh by now you would have understood that
the requirement is simple we need a
table right that table can come from
genomic data analysis it can come from
transcriptomic data analysis it can come
from metagenomics data analysis it does
not matter so uh we need a table and
that table can be read in as for example
Matrix or array or data frame into an
environment like R right and there are
differences in how these different
objects as I just mentioned uh Matrix
array and data frame are actually going
to deal or actually handling data of
different class or different types for
example Matrix will uh
will load or will actually consider data
that are only numerical data types right
array can consider again data of
consistent data right they're not only
numeric but they can also contain data
that is that are particularly
characterized character or one one data
type or one form of data type there is
no mix matching of data types in Matrix
or array Vector is just one dimension of
Matrix right only one
but very useful object that we will use
multiple times in the r data analysis is
the data frame so as as depicted in this
picture a data frame can
is an object which can be used to store
the tabular information or table table
of data like we have generated from by
structuring different atomics data but
data frame gives us a flexibility of
storing not only numeric data but it can
also store categorical data it can also
store logical data it can also store
character character data and Etc so this
this is very convenient and
because our data so far that we have
structured will involve for example at
least one column of
character data that refers to the
identity of either operation taxonomic
unit or Gene IDs or for example genomic
positions right um
or genomic annotations in this case
position is usually numeric so
annotation that can be
loaded along with the numerical data
that characterizes their levels across
different circles and some other useful
objects that are present in R is usually
list which is just a kitchen sink of all
the other types of data that we can put
in and they are very useful because
more often than not in our analysis we
will generate different types of data
and we can organize all of them into a
list that can be used to for example
load
a very a variety of different types of
data with variety of different
dimensions which is not actually
possible in the other
um types of objects right all the other
data frame metrics and array should have
consistency in their number of in their
Dimensions all the rows will should have
equal number of columns and all the
columns should have exactly equal number
of row entry in the row so that is
absolutely necessary
so we will we will also deal with this
little bit uh more detailed in the
upcoming sessions where we will load
tables into uh into our environment and
see how it is actually uh referred so we
will also quickly do that today so what
does this allow us to do right that's
the main important part why should we do
this right ah by doing this or by
loading data into environment like R
will actually help us to perform some
statistical analysis to basically learn
about the patterns in the data we can
for example perform or plot histograms
to understand data frequency we can
perform Scatter Plots to understand data
correlation between samples and there
are many more different ways to explore
and characterize large amounts of data
that we have usually in the
data analysis so understanding this data
then we will actually use several of the
representation that we actually use like
scatter plot or histogram to for example
visualize the data and to spot a
technical noise level or to spot a
specific threshold with which we have to
perform some very important statistical
analysis that is required for our
Downstream analysis methods
and this might involve something like
normalization using Quantum
normalization method this will inform
data transformation steps like
converting the scale into logarithmic
scale and um
several other transformation and and
Explorations will be discussed in the
next session immediately
so
we will also discuss how this table of
data can be converted into for example
representation like this and which is
more uh which gives us more biologically
meaningful inferences like we can
immediately understand the separation
between sample based on for example uh
the distances between the sample based
on the data variance as observed in the
PCA plot the right or the grouping of
sample according to expressions of
selective Selected Few genes
um in the form of a heat map as
represented in the plot on the left so
these are all only starting points and
it will give us hints and it will give
us pointers to right direction into what
are the samples that we can compare and
how we can set up this comparison right
those will also
uh we come into play so these
exploratory data analysis and
visualization in multiple different uh
options will give us a chance to see how
different methods like data mining
methods and how different machine
learning methods can be used to
group data objects by their expression
levels or by their taxonomic abundance
or by their by their mutation
frequencies to generally understand the
similarities and to differences between
the samples that can be related to their
phenotypical characteristics or
biological conditions of the data right
and we can also for example use this
data for
um
uh uh for applying
um
supervised machine learning methods
which can learn or which can create a
model from the data that we have
supplied and then make more predictive
uh
um prediction of the data that are
observed in the generally observed in
the real world data examples for example
to expand on this we can take a group of
for example we can take a
transcriptomics data analysis of a
specific cancer type and then perform
this perform supervised machine learning
analysis to understand the stages of
different uh different humor types and
then use a completely different data set
from The Real World data to apply the
prediction or to validate the prediction
of the model that we just prepared or we
just created using the input training
data set that we supplied to the
supervised machine learning model
so these are all different types of
Downstream analysis and the choice of
which analysis uh to be performed to
infer what uh impactful inferences that
we have to take will actually depend on
what are the exploratory data analysis
points to from our data so that is why
you will often see us discussing the
importance of Performing very uh useful
exploratory data analysis and
visualization up front when we are
exploring the patterns in the data
before setting up specific analysis
using statistical and advanced
statistical methods what we will discuss
so um if you have few more minutes I
will quickly I will reshare my screen
and I want to show you
some Associated resources in this case
two uh tell you how we can access this
data from the from the learn portal
so that is going to be very useful for
us let's say
um let me set up the shine this won't
take more than let's say five minutes
yes
Amazon is still working on sharing my
screen
I hope you can see my screen can
somebody reply me that whether you can
see the r coding course one
yes yes Dr raghav in there we can
thank you very much so so this is the
associated resources and sonalika has
actually gone through these resources so
I would go to again but several of the
resources are associated resources can
be accessed from here and you nothing
stops you from accessing what is going
to be discussed in the next session
right so I'm taking some of the examples
from the next session like this data
processing and visualization and reading
DNA sequences in R right those can be
very useful if you want to get generally
good introduction to R before we even
start right so one of the very useful
course that we will refer time and again
over the course of this program is the r
coding course one and which is very very
valuable for beginners who wants to get
uh
started with that so I want all of you
if you have access to this platform to
go to this lesson
and I will paste this in the chat
log in and go to this specific lesson if
you are logged in if you click on this
link that will open up their resources
for you and you can follow along with me
so what am I going to do I am going to
Simply access loading data in our lesson
then opening up this will start with an
introduction to how to set up R and what
is the use of RI this you can go through
this video resources to set up or
install R for your
um
computer but even before that if you go
down if you scroll down uh working
through the codes that are given in this
not only in this specific lesson but in
almost all of the r coding course
doesn't require you to install or in
your computer so it is actually platform
free or background free you can access
these lessons from anywhere right so how
do we do that so we go to learn the code
section where the basic idea of this
specific lesson is to take the table
that we have been discussing so far and
load it into our environment and then
reproduce and print out the table to see
how they are being
interpreted right so this is how we are
going to break down the code all the
codes are going to be shaded in black
and they're uh they are copy pasteable
and we will Define or we will actually
go through each and every portion of
this syntaxes uh at its fundamental
level for example
um just going through this one line will
actually introduce you to for example
the function that we need to load the
table and what are the requirements of
this function this function at least
needs to be told where the data is right
where the input file is that input file
can be located in your computer it can
be located in the internet that is
publicly available and followed by some
of the characteristics of your input
table whether or not in your table do we
have title for each and every column
that is the header so whether or not
that is present and and how are these
columns separated and what is the
character that separates this column the
character can be tab the character can
be comma that character can be semicolon
in some specific cases so this is these
are all characteristics of the input
file that we need to know before even
loading this to R if we don't provide
this to this function
the function will assume default values
and if the default value does not agree
with our sample or with our table
characteristics the table will not be
interpreted as as it should be
integrated so that is what was given
here you can for example extend this to
not only from text file in tab delimited
format and we have given you how to
import Excel files into R right so
reading Excel files into R requires a
module or requires a library to be
installed in arts environment so if you
are using going to use your own version
of R so you have to install this Library
into R before even using this function
read dot Excel SX that's there and
reading a comma separated version of the
file is just using a different
function instead of read dot table
function that we have been using right
so after going through this and after
for example uh going through some other
portions of how to check whether the
data is loaded or not usually we take
this function and their output and
redirect that to an object that we can
access and that we can check or verify
so that object is usually or always a
data frame when we use these functions
right so that is why they are
abbreviated as TN and R can use this
operator which is simply redirection
operator that takes the output of this
function and puts it into this object
right and we can again now verify the
contents of this object by simply
mentioning their name and then executing
in the RS console so that is what is
given here how different ways you can
verify uh the contents of the data frame
and make sure that all the necessary
um
rows and columns are actually ready so
to try or to test what you have learned
so far we go to the next section try it
yourself this is on our console and that
is loaded in the back end of the learn
portal so you will get uh to run our
commands and our codes in here so this
is not very straightforward it is
straightforward in that case just to
press run it will run but I want you to
read these instructions where we have
prepared this console to help you test
yourself what you have learned from the
previous section so how have we done
that so read this here we say that we
have deleted some important portions of
the code and that you need to uh
complete by understanding how it is been
done in the previous section so if we do
that let's say
if I don't complete it and run it just
like that is going to show me lot of
different errors right it just it's
going to throw first uh many error that
are not easily readable right that's how
programming languages are so it says we
need to actually uh for most of these
codes we need to take the files link
that is given here right this is the
link and we right click on this link and
copy the link address and to replace
this portion which is symbolic
and then right click on paste
okay so I I mentioned or I'm giving the
function where to find the data set from
and it should run now so I want to clear
this console let's clear this and then
run it
again is going to throw you an error
because now I notice that the function
which reads the table or which reads a
file is not complete so I complete the
function then clear it again and then
run it
now I get a success in running the code
and the answer is correct so I also get
the output right here and you can do the
same for using libraries also and that
is loaded in the back end and this is
actually giving uh
yeah okay so now it looks complete the
function looks complete and the path
where the file is located is not
complete so again change this copy link
address and then change this
and right click on paste it
and now it should be good to go uh I can
run let's see
and please observe what I get yeah I get
success in running the code but the
answer is incorrect so there is no
syntax error in my code but the intended
answer is not met so what is that the
intended answer is here right we have to
check the uh we have to print the data
import and view the data so the printing
portion of the data is not there so just
like the previous case I just print what
is given in the data frame so there is
nothing to be clear from this console so
I just run it again
so now I get success in running the code
the answer is correct and we have given
some more examples and some more extra
biological data sets for you to track so
that is for you to try so as before
closing we'll want go back to the lesson
and we want to want all of you to also
explore the second lesson which is going
to be the topic for the next session
where this console not only can give you
for example not only can
um give the outputs in the given output
area but it can produce graphs like this
and how to produce graphs like this is
what expand in this code that is what is
the topic of our next session I quickly
want to show you here uh
I see that the input file is already
filled up so I complete the syntax
and I see that there is another portion
of the syntax that is missing
and true and then say this come back and
see this portion of the missing you see
this and then
um yeah then run this
correct and this is not going to produce
any plots because that's not the
intended use but this will produce the
plot and let's see uh
okay the codes for producing box part is
incomplete
they can type box plot correctly and
then heat map then type histogram and
the data is missing from the histogram
DF and then run this
we will discuss in detail in the next
session but I just want to show you that
this can produce Graphics just as what
is discussed what is described in the
lesson or Associated resources or
learning the code sections can produce
exactly the same Graphics that you can
generate and then
um explore the contents of these
graphics and to understand the patterns
in your data so with that I will
conclude my part of today's session and
if you have any questions I'll be happy
to take it from there
from the chat box or if I will pass it
on to Spurs
I think yeah
this purse is going to be the next
person who is going to talk about
yeah yeah so so sorry actually I was
unable to unmute myself yeah sorry yeah
uh so thank you Dr rajinder uh Dr raghav
we have two questions uh
I suppose you haven't answered I just
I'll just read it read out those
questions
so the first question is is there a
difference between rna-seq and
transcriptomics
we I actually uh answered this during
the okay so you have answered this
question yeah okay
[Music]
yeah perfect so thank you thank you so
much I just wanted to confirm do we have
any other questions
so yeah if if no then yeah suppose you
can take it over and if yes you can type
it in the chat box while it's purchase
explaining you
thank you so much sir so um hello
everyone uh my name is Persian I'm the
marketing manager here at Pine biotech
so I'll I won't take much time of yours
because it's already we are up like we
are running late so I'll just uh quickly
uh tell you about the registration and
the resources which one would have
access to if they would enroll for this
program so by enrollment we mean that uh
there is a particular fee structure that
you need to pay uh so as to get enrolled
in this program and attend the further
uh live sessions of this particular
program
so uh this is the program page and
let me just share my share the link here
in the chat box so this is the program
page after the session you all can go
through this program page and uh take a
look about the sessions program overview
Etc so the name of the program is
Introduction to bioinformatics in our
getting started with r so we'll be
covering here about multiomics how one
can process the data statistical
analysis data visualization Etc so today
was the very first session and it was a
kind of an introductory session uh so we
covered all the resources which one
could have access to how the associated
online resources would work uh
everything was explained you very
extensively by Dr raghav in as well as
by sonalika how to sign up on the portal
update your profile how to navigate on
the micrological and portal Etc so this
is again the program overview as you can
see and when you'll scroll down you can
see a full-fledged
um curriculum for all the sessions which
we'll be conducting and maximum of the
sessions will be
live sessions because it includes coding
so those sessions would be live so the
first session we covered uh includes
introduction to Big Data in
bioinformatics introduction to
bioinformatics languages are using the
code playground loading data in our Etc
and Dr raghavendran show you the
associated online resources on the learn
portal already
so I won't be uh taking it again I'll
simply tell you about the
pricing part so first of all there is a
note
[Music]
there is a drop down menu here at the
right top a corner which through which
you can change your currency according
to your location so if someone is living
in a U.S region so they can change it
into USD if someone is living in Brazil
so they can change change it into a
Brazilian currency if in India then INR
if in Nigeria then NG and naira so for
now I'll be
choosing a INR and I'll be explaining
the resources and the subscription uh
accordingly so there as you can see on
my screen there are three different
tenures one is of 45 days then is of 60
and then is of 90s the common resources
which one would have access to when they
will enroll in this particular program
it would be online tutorials project
examples coding sessions session
recordings online Mentor Support Online
technical support then example Cloud
pipelines on T bio input server which is
our analysis
platform then after the completion of
the program you will have a certificate
or you'll earn a certificate which you
can surely use so as to upgrade your CV
and to show the recruiters that you are
yes you are a skilled uh you are skilled
in R language integrated with
bioinformatics and how you can analyze
biomedical data through it and also you
can Showcase in different uh social
media platforms like LinkedIn Etc
for better and for boosting up your
networking also so uh this is the these
are the common resources now what is the
difference between the three tenures is
in 45 days tenure you will go through
with the full-fledged training and uh
like you can clarify your doubts in
those live sessions which will be
conducted conducting or via the online
Mentor or technical support through the
Skype Group which sonalika uh told in
the beginning of the session now the
difference between the 60 and the 90s is
in 60 days with 45 days of training you
have two different opportunities one is
the one-on-one Mentor session so if
while going through your training part
you get stuck in uh like you have a
query and you get stuck somewhere you
can ask the project manager or the
community manager to fix up all of yours
with the mentor of 15 to 20 minutes kind
of an exploratory call you can get on a
call with him one-on-one clarify your
doubts and then move on further with the
training part
the second opportunity is to draft a
research proposal and present it to the
mentor for further evaluation and expert
feedback and the outcome for 60 days
tenure is a poster presentation so you
can create a poster of your research and
you can present it
and you can present it uh in different
International Conference and research
Symposium and also we conduct biannual
research Symposium so you will be surely
getting a chance to to Showcase your
research idea in those Symposium now in
90 days tenure you have another two
opportunities obviously one is
one-on-one mental sessions and second is
to complete a full-fledged independent
research project to develop your own
independent research project and the
further outcome of this 90 days tenure
is a research publication in a
peer-reviewed journal so this was the
difference between the three tenures now
talking about the pricing part uh the 45
days the pricing of the 45 days is 7 500
then is
10 000 for 60 days and then 90 days it's
15 000 and right now we are providing
with 20 scholarship so the program has
just started we'll be ending up the
scholarship part today itself so please
go and Avail the opportunity uh so as to
be a part of the program so this was
about the
pricing in INR now I'll change the
pricing into USD to Showcase you what
exactly the pricing in uh us uh USD
dollars looks like so the first uh for
the 45 days it's dollar 150 sorry it's
dollar 150 then for 60 days it's dollar
300 and for 90 days it's dollar 450.
again we are providing with 20
scholarship on all the 10 years and uh
to Avail this
have shared the steps to register in the
chat box you need to simply visit the
link here I have shared and also shubham
has reshared it you need to choose the
tenure according to your wish and your
requirements whether it is 45 60 or 90
and after choosing the tenure you need
to click on this buy now option so when
you'll click on this buy no option you
will be redirected to the payment
checkout page where you need to Simply
write the coupon code Type the coupon
code that is take
20 click on this apply button
your coupon code is successfully applied
you need to fill this user details and
click on this check box and select the
payment mode which you want to apply for
either swipe or PayPal then fill out
your credit card details and proceed
with the payment check out so this was
the steps to register for the program
and now if anyone is having any doubt
regarding the
scholarship or the registration or the
payment procedure please feel free to
Ping in the chat box and we'll be here
to assist and guide you
thank you
so I guess I have converted the price
bundle to US dollar already and the
price for US dollar is for 45 days it's
150 for 68 dollar 300 and then for 90
it's 450 and I suppose it's it's clear
now
enroll
[Music]
do you come with your own project and
data or is provided omics logic so it's
both ways you can also come up with your
idea your research question and our
Mentor will guide you accordingly uh
we'll be starting with the training part
and then we'll be guiding you how you
can review our literature find a good
data set on which you can work on
prepare a proper methodology
Etc so it is both ways you have a
research interest and you don't know how
to develop a research question we'll be
guiding you that also if you have a
research question we'll be guiding you
that also how you can further develop a
full-fledged research project out of
that research question so it it's it's
both ways
yes
okay so Dr raghav with has also answered
this question thank you Dr raghav
how can we apply for the scholarship so
we have provided you with the coupon
code already take 20 you need to Simply
uh like click on this buy now option you
need to follow the steps to register
and then apply this 20 scholarship if
you are asking for more scholarship then
please mail us at marketing
at the rate of mixlogic.com uh so our
team will surely revert back to you and
will provide you with a suitable
solution which would definitely help you
out and uh you can surely enroll in this
particular program also we have an
official number and it's active on
WhatsApp
so it's
9876-134120
yeah thank you shubham for sharing the
details so this is this is the mail
address if someone is seeking more
scholarship than 20 person they can mail
us out and this is the contact number
it's an official number you can contact
us via WhatsApp we can have a direct
WhatsApp telephony conversation also and
we can discuss it in more extensive or
comprehensive manner
thank you any other question anyone
sorry
um so I guess there are no more
questions
and uh we are good to uh end this
meeting
so uh yeah so thank you everyone and we
are looking forward uh like
for the next session basically a session
two Okay so
some okay Aya is asking one question for
option 90 days you mentioned it includes
publication who will be working on the
manuscript beside the first author the
person who worked on the project
um so yes Aya and I guess Dr
raghavendran would be the like would be
the correct person to answer this
question uh Dr raghavendra could you
please unweet yourself and answer this
question
it's basically you and
um me and if you need any technical help
from sonalika then she will also chime
in right that's that's how the
Publications are actually made if uh if
the work involves only you and you are
able to perform this analysis without
much of the uh other uh helps or other
counterparts then it's it's going to be
you as a first author and yeah and me
and maybe yeah that's all
nothing else so if uh yeah
and Ilia might be also the last when we
are going to discuss with him for
necessary inputs for making this
publication into a good shape
or if you want to just learn the methods
and apply the methods yourself and then
use publication so we can discuss about
the authorship
um at a much later level the idea or the
intent is to
um
make or help you with reasonable
projects that you can showcase that you
can publish and that you can use to
learn the techniques and necessary
details so that's that's what I get here
so it depends on how many how much of
work we did if it involves me working on
the project then of course you have to
share the authorship and if it involves
me just guiding then it depends upon uh
how much I just simple mentorship then
you can just mention that thanks for the
discussion with uh
I hope your question is uh answered Ayah
thank you anyone is having any uh in any
question please feel free to uh bring in
the chat box or you can unmute yourself
and ask that's completely fine
foreign
meeting so thank you everyone for
joining the first session of
introduction to bioinformatics and our
hope you gained something new today
uh and uh we'll be looking forward uh so
we could have maximum participation for
this particular program and we'll be
looking forward so that you can join in
the next upcoming session at the session
two
okay and there is one more question
there are courses that require a Whitman
so I could not pass them are there
opportunities to get a scholarship
um so uh Ella yes so there are some
courses which have been marked as start
and you cannot uh pass out like
those courses uh definitely yes we are
providing with scholarship and that is
what we discussed that you can mail us
at marketing
omixlogic.com and we'll be uh discussing
about the scholarship also the second
thing is
uh for those courses to have access to
those courses there is our starter
subscription which you can have access
to let me share my screen and I'll show
you
in just a moment
so if you click on this uh pricing after
you have signed up and if you'll click
on this pricing uh
tab
just a moment it's taking time to load
you can see here uh
let's try taking time to load
yeah perfect so uh this is what I was
talking about this is the starter
subscription and in the starter
subscription you would have access to
all those courses which you are saying
that uh you are not
eligible to go through with those
lessons and uh courses because they have
been mugged as start so you can click on
this buy now and proceed with the
payment check out and have uh access to
all those start lessons
thank you
so do you have any further question
anyone
okay so I don't think so now uh we have
any further question and it's a final
goodbye and thank you to everyone uh
thank you everyone for joining take care
have a nice day ahead
bye